yellow welcome to this broadcast yeah
what does my contact and Isis you say it
was his fault okay yeah I'm late like
three minutes but that's not really a
big deal yeah okay i hope you had a good
monday so far and i'm going to start
right now with a couple of blitz games
okay so five minute chest let's see what
i can do um tool casts who is that let
me check florian hunt go yeah that's uh
I don't know him personally but he
played a quite a bit not far away from
from my place so I'm going to have a
bogo there what is he doing trying to
find the book that a certain I am wrote
maybe yeah this is a line that I had on
the board last year can stir and exam
the lender Minh the lender man played
with e for not with g 3 mm okay let's go
96 yeah Alec frosh says good time of day
to all all of you is what he's saying to
all of you my chest friends yeah this is
a yeah mos typical way of greeting his
audience guess it's kind of a trademark
some of this can we see a bit of the
bangko with an early Queen a 5 mm not
sure I don't really play the Banco as a
question is there an addicted of the
version version of my book um yeah
the abdomen chest will definitely
release um and an e-book that's wrong
let me phrase it differently you know
something like a chess base version yet
like a CB of something file no and this
is certainly going to be in the works
but I'm not sure when it is completed
what is definitely available is a kindle
version now if you are an Amazon you can
buy the kindle version but not yet
something in chessbase format someone
says I should play the ball cloud no
Avant I really don't like to play
complete [ __ ] yeah someone says I
never play the gruene felt that's true I
really don't feel like I know it in any
reasonable detail to play it okay I'm
going back with that night that night is
not doing so much on a six maybe rugae
three years away okay c5 can do that
yay especially I mean I playing blitz
right and against very good opponents
and if you play this so-called bone
cloud opening you're just lost like
immediately and I don't like to be lost
immediately and you has a question am I
still selling copies of my book this I
just have one left i think really
exactly one
km try to trade stuff to get a decent
night against bed bishop kind of
scenario the bishop 1g2 is really not
that great so this and I'm controlling C
and a house so that cannot be bad this
is kind of what you want in the bogo
almost an ideal scenario okay maybe I
can get in the Queen see to hear i will
give to brooke f2 is actually threatened
now okay prevented that so Quincy to is
this any good it's not bad just wonder
if there's something better mmm Quincy
to would basically forced the Queen
trade takes takes look a one rupee to
check up da this is what I'm not liking
it gets to the d6 pawn mmm anything
better okay maybe this for loop see 10
roots III
k i'm going rook see one queen and night
against Queen at Bishop is nice so I
don't mind the rook trade
okay so he doesn't mind to this end game
yeah in this end game black is better
but it's not that much I'm better
because of that d5 pawn that's very very
nice target but not not easy to to
really get something substantial out of
it I can take it
ok I'm going to take it
hmm ok difficult to to really go for
winning this position and five king of
69 physics it's probably drawn from the
drone he only has that d5 weakness and
that's not enough to play seriously for
win for me
yeah teak say a way to get to the age
three Pawn maybe hmm maybe
maybe I can do a little something here
takes quick quick intakes and
threatening kini 5 and I've also
threatening to go over to age three
maybe the problem is that if i move the
night remove the night yes King see form
and it's still wrong not much to do it's
still a drone oh it's surprising don't
tell me why it wants to try to win this
position that would be when bit of a
weird idea I may be running around with
the king maybe I underestimated that we
offer you offered me a draw actually
yeah I think a draw is fair i cannot
cannot really do anything yeah he agreed
yeah it looked it looked nicer but I
couldn't really get anywhere okay so
there have been a couple of comments I
think or questions let's see there's
something someone says about my book the
huebner variation is very complex yeah
it is it really is there's the question
what do I think about the last world cup
results aronian autocall Avadh kramnik
out karwan out i'm not completely sure
against who respectively they went out I
think ramnik lost to a draicon which can
happen I mean the difference between the
two is not that great especially if it
comes to rapid and blitz and they had a
rapid play or if i'm not mistaken um
yeah I mean topalov and Kara wanna they
didn't really have any pressure in that
event because they are already qualified
for the candidates and this is not so
much about the event itself but about
the qualification spots so it's really
am not that important that that
tournament as weird as it sounds as long
as you if you are already finished off
if you're already qualified for the
candidates it's not really that
important and
and therefore i think it's not that yeah
kawana lost ya mamedyarov i mean that's
not an also a huge deal and sweet let's
also not a big difference to depart off
i mean deccan can easily happen that
swidler wins against the part of ok
there's a question how far along with
the hassle stay ova n da book taken
waiting as far as nvm knowledge goes and
that's an interesting question if you
form this is a book about theoretical
end games like with reduced material the
very basic stuff and this is actually
this book is totally enough for for very
high level actually i think mayor up to
up to master level definitely and what
you need us at 1.22 also study more
strategically focused and games and this
is what you can do from let's say the
end game menu by the red ski or or other
books there you then you didn't need
something in addition but for
theoretical end games i think the de la
via book is completely sufficient for a
very long time yeah I wonder if he can
probably put lots of pressure here on
the sea for porn something went wrong
here in this and in this game night b2
is a big problem
and Luke c2 is going to play b5 her I
really screwed this up quite badly be 5c
5 might still be somewhat okay maybe
maybe ok so I'm going to try to complete
development now I just doubled that
splits very simple but very effective
hmm wow that was a bad game kanki I
cannot keep that porn I was sick of that
or food or for some kind of code to play
here not really I could not be five now
now maybe I can irritate him a little
bit at least not really yeah it's just
not playable okay we should be six as a
threat yeah maybe cheeks I can check
here first and then take I don't know if
this is any good it's good
ok I'm going away here I just got deform
for the rotten position
yeah the bad thing is that it's all wins
really all wins maybe this one to charge
isolate the sea porn if he takes King
III I asked ah drooped III hides the
loss anyway someone asked about my
opinion about fashion lagrave see one of
the best five to six players in the
world not sure okay I can resign that
one that was a really bad game so what
happens let's see I mean isn't mdl like
number 15 or so why would you number be
number five in your opinion I mean he's
very strong of course but there are a
couple of somewhat better guys I mean
world number five was that at the moon
that like koala or some somebody and
he's not quite there no I never played
the bong cloud pletely really am I'm
relieved I've got the good sense of
humor I'm not playing this nonsense
really don't okay playing branimir here
we have a reti opening okay Bishop e3
I'm going for F 685
I think maxime certainly has a good
chance in the world camp and the world
cup that really is the case he's good in
blitz and rapid and why not it's
possible I don't have a clear favorite
in that event really not I Nakamura
sorry I have one a camera of course
okay I'm taking the center in this game
as it's nice there's a question I'm
someone says hi he's 12 rated 1250 and
loses most of his games due to blunder
two blunders any tips how to play better
and stop blundering pieces um yeah this
is certainly very important it as long
as you um blunt the material and do so
regularly it just is almost impossible
for you to score score points there are
a couple of things that you can do
someone says do chess puzzles this is an
interesting way to do it the other thing
is just play as many games as you can
another thing is what you should try to
do is not play um not play quicker time
controls so don't play absolutely don't
play bullet chest this is this is really
important it's completely bonkers if you
want to try to improve don't play bullet
and don't play quick blitz yeah like you
can do like 10 minute games maybe if you
want if you have limited time but don't
do like three minutes or even if not
five minute um it's important that you
have some time to think and the most
important thing that causes those
blunders is things that are not quite
coordinated in your position for example
uncut unprotected pieces yeah we come
weak squares and try to make a conscious
effort to not have pieces unprotected
squares week and so on try to yeah get
some harmony harmony in your position
okay if you if you if I'm going for an
example my position here it's not super
grade or anything but notice that the
only thing that it's kind of
defendant is my queen yeah and this poem
on b7 so not that much and on Whiteside
almost everything is kind of defended
and this is not just the case of where
you say okay as long as this defendant
you cannot blend it it's just that the
position is much easier to play as long
as the pieces I kind of have most
harmoniously working together and this
is the key so what I'm what can I do now
I don't see a clear idea here in this
position stream shouldn't be down I
think it should be ok I mean I can't put
that knight on c3 but I'm not quite sure
what it's doing that ok now i'm
attacking the airport at least maybe
this is what I'm doing okay over to c6
taking beef or twice but I'm not quite
positive what I'm doing here in general
terms going on that diagonal here he
wants to go night c 4 26 I guess
I don't know
any advice how to avoid getting in time
trouble hmm let's in fact a difficult
thing um it's difficult once you get
into the habit of spending lots of time
to get out of it one thing that I do
recommend is to to write down your time
make notes about how much time you spend
on each move and try to figure out where
you spend the time on if it is mostly in
the opening you should really increase
your opening study because it's really
not acceptable to have to have a huge
time spent on one moves that you could
could have known of course that doesn't
mean that you have to learn everything
by heart and so on but you you cannot
let's say after ten moves have spent an
hour that that shouldn't happen yeah I
cannot go before unfortunately I would
love to wow he really allows this it's
it's surprising okay I can't cover this
and now how do you defend these three I
guess you don't okay 95 some trickery
here oh wow interesting t group is six
and then it's got 95 hmm very nice trick
Roxy three takes takes a B let's do it i
don't have much time try to use my own
see porn
okay what is he going to do then look be
six or what to know that I'm shaking
anyway I'm taking this now i can take
here just bones he just promotes how can
I lose this game I'm such a [ __ ] after
this we turn of events no don't give me
that one ah come on what a sick joke I
mean he's just totally losing completely
losing what am I doing here rooked
history and then it's got a six don't
give me that one it's just amazing a six
and he is winning after his success how
lucky can you be amazing we need is full
of weaknesses this position that he has
I can take on g3 for example and as I
just thought okay I win anyway I don't I
didn't really look I can take this this
and then 95 or what auntie resigns I
thought it wins anyway when a six white
is winning that's crazy that's really
crazy ah ok wow what a bad streak i've
lost like all of them right ok so let's
do something else there go for some
sharp line victory seven i don't know no
one know that guy
yeah this is the sameish variation
sharpline okay guys playing it in the
style of but we make a cup of blanca
from from the 30s as a question what do
you do in a position when you absolutely
have no idea of what to do and can't
find any decent plans or most improve
your position try to find some
prophylactic move or something like that
yeah there's someone already writing
improved bad pieces that's not a bad
idea at all if you don't really know
what to do checking your pieces for
possible improvement is an idea yeah
like if one piece is totally misplaced
you can try to try to improve that one
that's very often a good idea the other
thing is sometimes we sometimes lose
track of what is really essential in a
position here we do all kinds of things
at the same time and we forget what is
the most important thing about it and
sometimes this is helping if you for one
moment just wait like a moment I think
okay wait what is really the most
important thing is it really that porn
that I'm attacking or is it rather that
his night is misplaced and he's lacking
defenders at the King side this is often
important to just not being just so much
mm yeah not sticking to particular idea
but rather thinking about it again if
really it if we really look at the most
important thing yeah c4 was black was
bad and this was especially bad is
giving me a piece and i hope i hope a
win
I couldn't win a game yet in the session
so i hope this is one win it really
should be yeah he resigned okay that was
nice in 40 grab liguori or parent that's
a very strong GM from Russia that's I
never played him I think probably we get
a News oh ok let's go for the samish
again it's very risky not very good but
quite often funny
no I don't really want to play crazy
openings it's a question what do I think
about turn based online chats in terms
of improvement yeah it's not a bad idea
at all the thing is that very often
people are just reproducing what their
computers are saying and this can
sometimes happen if you play play online
yeah this is Grand Master Perrin he's
really that's his name Gregorio Perrin
he's one of the most promising Russian
junior players why not the green felt
because I'm unable to memorize that
opening and it's not really my style I
think okay here here this guy already
felt like yes to do something drastic to
not being stung to the ground I have to
agree so what do we do now aged six I
guess
wow that's a that's a very aggressive
move cool stuff ok I think I can take
your first yes to go King aruch f7 and
now if I take here and what is he doing
like know if was not working I don't
quite get it I don't quite get it I
really don't think that it works
objectively but right now I don't even
understand the idea
okay I'm getting rid of this what now
Queen d2 mf3 a 393 and King to f2 I
don't I don't really see a huge attack
fam
pretty save on f2 actually it looks like
let's go here
I mean the H file is rather my mydle
mania when f6 is hitting the wind would
be nice it's really a strong GM peace
lies around 2606 Andrew gage one and age
seven collapses yeah okay a couple of
bad games but one really nice win okay
c-can we follow up on that in mortal in
mortal doing there there are someone
someone quoted tirage like if you don't
basically saying if you don't know what
to do hope that your opponent does
something stupid and that sometimes too
I mean what's definitely um something
that I like to mention his irises there
is this this this idea that it's better
to have a bad plan than no plan at all
and this is nonsense it really is
nonsense if you have no plan yeah then
just do nothing and don't do something
stupid okay so we have a queen pawn
opening here with white not doing
something too aggressive but it's
definitely very solid home queen bee
three is something that might happen ok
I'm going to liquidate this keep it
simple for Bishop t6 later yeah it's
it's a London with white being a temp up
but it doesn't matter that's from from
Boris a Brooks book book and pretty
pretty good line especially simple to
play
um so
yeah I'm trading this Bishop now okay
let's keep it simple take their take
this and queen bee eight and now up for
b5 yeah here mister ugh frosh is right
it is a London system with white being a
tempo up but as a Brooke said well even
a tempo up it's not really any and he
has no big threats there hmm don't quite
get what white is doing is he getting an
attack here maybe with rookie 3g 3 as
usual I'm kind of under estimating my
opponents resources but I have Brooke FF
Queen Queen f4 right
Luke g3 Queen f4 should be okay out
covering age six and I can go look at 34
some kind of repetition but I got Queen
d2 may be interesting hmm what is this
does he want to get more pieces into the
attack maybe there's a question if my
book is supposed to be a complete
repertoire against you for why doesn't
it have a line against the jump-off ski
because it isn't a complete repertoire
and it's not advertised as that it's
it's complete against d4c for let's say
but it's not having the the Queen
foreign openings t4c 493 and the thing
is those are really not that dangerous
and there are books about that g6 I
didn't really appreciate they're not
good that's not good
yeah someone says you can use beating
default sidelines by boys I've look for
the rest that's true this is the book
that I was referring to earlier and now
he gets green takes age 6 blah ok ff4
maybe no it doesn't do that doesn't play
it ok not sure why not I mean my
position is still bad so he has some
some leeway rook to f7 Luke f6 this
could this is helpful if I get it in I
think it could have killed me already
somehow
hmm it's not really fun cannot move the
night queen is also difficult 26 for f8
or something or queen evade Queen Queen
evade yeah that might be might help okay
let's let's see can I get this end I can
get the night over to g6
ok that is this this is no quite okay I
think he's got the apron but I will
always have come to play against his
King age five is hanging now okay this
is kind of brutal but look g3 queen of
three wins here we go very lucky it was
lucky but he didn't play it well he just
gave me too much too much play okay
let's see um I often mentioned the book
move first think later do you agree with
the author on the subject of not
evaluation of position first before
finding moves and there are many things
that are right quite often you really
see the move first and then kind of kind
of find out what's the reasoning behind
it really happens quite quite often what
is my best draw winning a tournament as
my rating of opponent um my best win in
a tournament was I won against
Grandmaster makarevich at the time he
was only rated 2595 only because he also
was felled above 2700 at one point and I
basically had the one moment where he
was below 26 but it was a very nice win
the game is not available anymore and
the best draw in terms of opponents
rating was them can screen mastic
revolutio from the Ukraine that was in
2011
I was playing for this trick it's not
working he's got the check I was
thinking 95 but it's not working no that
only 25 95 is referring to two grew
witches usually writing is usually it's
above 26 so I would have loved to win
against someone above 26 but at the
moment at this particular moment he
wasn't and the best draw was mr. Crewe
Verushka yes he's 27 now in fact him he
offered me a draw in a position where I
was a lot better but I didn't really
have the guts to continue it was also
because I needed this final
international master normand the draw
was fantastic in that regard and I
didn't want to risk it even though the
position as I said was really crying for
being continued yeah let's see this
position here he can put this night on
c4 now it's probably about equal him
hmm what I don't believe this Bishop age
seven I'd win some material right now
get to know this he's got night a three
at the end maybe but still that's an
exchange who let's see do I want to
return the exchange here it's no reason
really to do that I can do this move and
then to see Sir than to see five yeah
Andrew k 1 that's nice should be enough
to win yeah he resigned so I'm getting
some wins in so I only had a really bad
start okay so um ok so back a couple of
question what is the theoretical early
asian of this line night and 3906 c4d
693 Bishop g7 ephors castles wait wait
wait wait you know can I do this year no
exam so let's let's do this for real
someone asks about this him oh I'm sorry
I actually screwed it up immediately the
question was this e 4 cancels 3 c 6 what
is the theoretical evaluation with a
quick d 5v5 and so on and the issue with
this line is I think Bishop d3 after
which d 5 e 5 is not that great black
usually does this and then aged 3
entrance poses to some a five base set
up this has been played quite a bit by I
think it is is that can Pinsky from
Poland I think it's kempinski its
playable yeah why does a little bit
better as always in the kings
but it's nothing special and there is
another question and this is this d4
Knight f6 e4 e5 Teague's here III yes
this this is a line that I play Knight
h3 night bc 69 f 4 we should be fine
check bishop d two castles what should
white do now I took the guy here said he
took before which isn't best he can just
do this 93 as a good move you still have
95 both of them and the black Bishop PM
has to trade or move again so that is
some that is really am really nice for
white ok I'm going for a new game ok I
have to this is a serious one I'm
playing a friend of mine this is grand
master Daniel house rod he's some living
this is a dewlap of someone who lives
like ya know maybe 5 25 miles away from
me that's funny yeah he's a grandmaster
with the 25 something rating I came do I
take play it sound and solid no let's
play a little bit more interesting
interestingly with this ok I'm taking
this
there is no match against the girls
really not and I really have no interest
in this kind of match why would I I mean
I really avoid to if there's one person
here that I could set on that on that no
playlist that would really be him it's
just an awful waste of time to play him
I mean you never get anything
interesting on the board yeah and he's
doing this stupid rook against Luke
saying a thing and the games are always
they are never interesting this is
simply the case because he really rarely
actually tries to play well he just
tries to win on time every game and it
really it's just kind of it always hurts
a little bit because it doesn't even try
to play well yeah he doesn't even try if
he has got the alternative of getting
and opposite colors bishops that are
dead draw near but he's got a minute
more on the clock and having something
that's better for him then he does the
thing with the opposite colored bishops
because he can so easily shuffle around
aimlessly okay that's an interesting
position and it's actually quite sharp
yeah I can also take twice on d5 which
is quite interesting but this shouldn't
be too bad
mmm it gives me that Bishop interesting
okay I'm taking it let's not promote him
yeah there are some techniques here like
Bishop f5 look at five stuff like that
he's a very good technical play I have
to be alert there so c6 maybe night
before do I have to liquidate this here
I don't know yeah come on it's very very
unassuming but didn't see anything great
King g7 can go to c6 push up the eighth
i look at six maybe this form of g6 look
26 rookie a door what is he doing near
me I can go back to the age okay seven
coming i'm offering a draw yeah it's
really a dead draw I mean why can try if
he wants because of his but he's a
better player simply but position is not
anything at all when he's 40 seconds
down okay that that's okay really I mean
white has a somewhat yeah some bowling
advantage may be so let's see can I use
this somehow here this is this kind of
pinning situation
probably not Bishop f5 king of Cigna
it's also not really doing anything yeah
i can go Bishop g5 in this position yes
no meaningful check I believe everything
is on dark squares
I tries to go around here okay well
everything is protected him I can try to
to run all the way there maybe it's this
is losing awesome that it looks fun can
I if I take now there and don't do these
three is this kind of crazier it's
probably gets crazier I cannot take
really focus seven Roxy six meters funny
that's really funny Luke c6 made is
threatened actually and that also
happens after i take that that's cute
okay I probably shouldn't have done that
and many relatively simple ways for a
drawer wagga think
you
hmm not quite clear anymore I'm drawing
this
okay six look f5s an idea kind of cute
him I could be sucked father could be
zoosk one I suit swag myself this is
really crazy from that dead position
yeah okay so it was a total [ __ ]
idea to go to see five again I was too
ambitious trying for something when I
can just stay and it's totally dead
anyway that was completely useless he
was losing that was stupid really stupid
okay okay let's see
he asked me if we can watch the video
later said no a coupon life yeah someone
says it's impressive that Willy Gus can
find so many drawing openings and
defenses that is indeed true it's really
yes made this an art form yet to play
the absolute completely the most
lifeless stuff ever I he really finds it
that's really amazing TS could call her
or something yeah this is probably the
final game in this show depends how long
that is if it's the same opening funny
it's exactly the same opening okay can
you take back a draw of an over the
board if your opponent sings so long
about that he gets into time travel no
you cannot if you offer a draw that draw
offer still stands yeah it absolutely
stands as long as the other guy has not
made a movie can accept okay I'm trying
to be be quick here I have some doubts
about the quality of this I have to be
perfectly honest but maybe I'm
threatening e4 in this position my
kindle 91 it's not a threat really
I'd see what his queen is doing okay can
kick this Bishop away going for night
before 95 is somewhat annoying though
it's not really a great position hmm c5
is a strange move
I'd really like to get rid of that
knight on d5 maybe this okay I manage
this but yeah that's not bad knight c6
screen for maybe hmm hey you rated 2012
kiss makes a mistake it's not fair i'm
playing that well I mean I playing
really badly but stuff yeah Queenie form
I have no good move him he just
completely kills me this guy TS color or
whatever yeah someone says that how
would you see how does he get all those
lifeless positions against the char
players well some players who really do
play sharp stuff like that send a camera
what they do is they play complete
bonkers or [ __ ] openings against him
a 6 aged a 611 h6 some just some
nonsense to get out of common theory and
then they kind of technically do crazy
things to him he really is a bad score
against a camera for example or really
bad score against yacht good this is the
craziest thing I really have no score no
score against Vegas I mean I'm losing
like every game
and against yard poder mr. leubronn I've
got like fifty percent and he's got the
positive scoring and swelling us very
very easily even I mean and the games
look look like he just wins without any
big effort sometimes well I can't simply
cannot do it I don't know what what what
is happening I mean did this game I'm
playing and playing totally bad this
game no and he sees stuff very nice game
by this guy I mean as I said I really
played bad bad bad but he's punishing it
really nicely
I don't think I would have taken that
pawn but it doesn't matter it's just a
complete win you can take this now okay
let's do it as very zero counterplay
doing a one queen e 1 this is what I'm
trying to say the only thing is this
rather slow g 4 h3 takes mmm is there
something now each retakes hmm it wasn't
really necessary Kings
hmm if i move the night he's got this
chick then we win so i probably have to
do this hear hear the bishop is hanging
on me too i mean it doesn't really
matter but I take this is called Queen
each form and it's got clean edge for
anyway so I cannot check he
unfortunately I have no check okay I
have to do this so they only move to
continue for one or two moves so any
trick that I can go forward that's that
sets you have to resort to try to win or
do something in such a crappy position
hmm it's that good I have this check now
here Queen g2g for checking back my ads
probably probably does win ok away
probably for anything i need the bishop
here ok so it gives me that let's take
it g4 check this helping probably not
someone is not putting me away I mean
it's of course winning Queen edge for
made going for the cheapest of the cheap
almost almost a check him and then then
g-form kind of continues it's got eight
seconds seven seconds and we're offering
a draw I really really aren't some
result here yeah okay he took the draw
it's just the worst game ever ah ok
so
and so on us why am i complaining that
auriga's liquidates to draw from better
positions why would I be annoyed about
that because he basically says that he
doesn't care about the game of chess he
wants to win on time this is the only
thing he wants to win and he doesn't
really care if it's a good move or not
he keep he rather plays total [ __ ]
and we know on time then trying to
really win on position and this is just
crap this is what it is this is just not
chess this is just clicking aimlessly
around and I really don't see what the
point is anyway um there's a question
going to do it do it look at this
someone asks about a particular line
there's this oops sorry c6 this a six
how do I play whereas black if white
doesn't make the mistake of a four and
just throws a couple of moves I have
troubles when I play Queen since 7am
opponents are playing see one yeah this
line is just bad for black avoided a six
is pretty bad why would you play a 60
what you I mean this line is ok for
black but we rather want to play Queen a
five let's say oops didn't want to move
this Queen a five is a good move I have
to do this not really user interface
Queen a5 is very playable on of course
still night the night there and Queen B
6 is also decent I wouldn't play a 6
knots not that not such a great idea a4
is indeed a mistake em then a 5 is nice
you get here I get here but a 4 will not
be played by good players they will go
fo and just take the center I know I
like the other lines a bit more I mean
you can do it so it's not like terribly
um yeah the thing is with the with them
I don't want to talk about what I kasbah
that's great is he's really a good
player he's excellent and technical end
games it's just that sometimes it would
be good if you just says okay this is
really totally dead and it's useless it
just useless to shuffle around and just
just call it a draw okay um so do I want
one more game my company let's go one
more game here and then that's it we
started a bit side a bit late
and that game is not really running I
was just using it for analysis celess
the names in them so one more one more
game by the way guys make sure tomorrow
there's a new show starting by John
Watson it's a it's 9 p.m. central
european time 3 p.m. east coast where
you can ask John questions anything
related to chess opening theory and what
not is an excellent theoretician so get
your questions ready okay so we have a
electrons to fans here interesting don't
see that too often i went with e4 for
change let's grab some space but i guess
black is used to that in the end i can
see often have this kind of position
where you are slightly behind in terms
of space
k Queen d2 i'm not sure if someone is
asking stupid questions the thing is in
the chat it sometimes I sometimes
overlook at simply it's it's just too
much going on playing the games and so
on the choice 9 p.m. central european
time one hour earlier than my show
yeah lettuce I'm not sure I'd sure what
black is doing here shuffles around
let's do this I know it looks a bit
crazy but why I don't really know what
he does I video does not have be six or
so I really don't see any idea that
black has q this one I don't know night
to be six said something I can also
sacrifice on h6 that could be
interesting already I like this annoyed
it's probably not yet working let's gain
some more space okay take it um yeah and
so on the guy wat with the a6 line in
the fianchetto i don't know i mean if
you if it was recommended to you by your
coach and as you said is a decent player
maybe ask him what to do I mean I'm
really known expert I'm just kind of
skeptical about this line look at it by
the way was a weird decision now Queen
f7 mate looks kind of kind of
problematic I don't really see how we
defends it rook e8 Bishop h7 is also
made
yeah there was a nice way to end a quick
one yeah so nice little bonus game yeah
i'm closing this broadcast now i hope
you enjoyed it and make sure to watch
John show tomorrow there was a question
is I was curious someone says he's
curious about the technical versus
positional player debate is it that a
positional play as just a lazy
calculator or the technician simply
index patient has a lots of raw energy
or is there something to the distinction
um hmm I don't know let's start with one
thing i'm going to ask our answer that
question of course and the thing
positional player I always find that a
bit of a strange word um I tried to use
strategic and tactical the strategies
just someone who really tries to UM it's
like it's a little bit like the
strategist it's the guy who buys value
stocks there on the stock market yeah he
says okay I want to have solid values
and I want to have space I want to have
the bishop pair something to put in the
bank something for later let's say he
wants to build about that it's a builder
and the tactical player quite often
wants to do something very dynamic use
use the moment let's say and very often
it comes to one simple thing choice of
openings yeah the kind of openings that
lead to more direct battle all the kind
of openings that give you um those
long-term values if you think me I'm I
consider myself to be more of a
strategic player I try to have openings
where I have solid values yeah something
pawns in the center I'd like to get the
bishop pair I like to get
an extra porn in the center those
long-term things where I feel like if
the game takes a natural course I'm okay
the technical player maybe values
dynamics higher and would rather give up
short long-term things for short term
ideas offer some ideas that are not that
apparent yet that might come later this
is like if you put the stock market um
idea or reference in this is a guy who
would speculate on something um yeah
this guy asked after the opening you
really have the mercy of the current
position and what's concrete um you have
to do what the position demands of you
you really don't have that much of a
choice in terms of yeah being very
aggressive or doing something long term
or so on I mean very often it it really
is something you have to do a certain
thing but the choices are often set
pretty early on I mean very often for
example if you if you have a normal
opening like this if you are a
strategist you probably don't want to
play like d4 when it opens up early on
you don't have an extra sent upon you
don't have a dominance in the center you
probably want to play Bishop b5 and play
something something long term yeah where
you where you build up on the position I
have no opinion about the global stock
market I'm sorry I have no idea I have
no idea really I'm not an expert at all
when I was working in the bank I didn't
do any stock market analysis a friend of
mine who is doing stock market analysis
feels like it is pretty blown up at the
moment it's not really a buying market
but I really cannot tell
and get a question here by that guy with
the positional in term and technical
players it experienced player yeah it's
the choice of opening really you're
trying to you try to get something that
that you feel is something that you are
playing well in yeah yeah Oh everybody
has their preferences I like to play for
a safe King for example I choose my
opening according to that I try to not
play an opening where my king and slit
aureus Lee bad why don't I don't try to
give up the bishop ever don't have any
clear clear value from it well the
technical player maybe does that you
know let's say an opening like the cheek
or in defense of the Queens gambit and I
could never play that because I have to
give up the bishop pair from somewhat
unclear compensation okay guys this is
this is really really over here this
show I have to close it there's a
question thoughts about the Petrov good
opening and ask tomorrow ask jon is a
good opening expert I'm ending this
broadcast now thanks guys for watching
till next week bye